scp-682 vs scp-5871  could the knife that retroactively  erases its victims from the timeline  finally remove the hard to destroy  reptile from our past present and future  scp-682 was bound in place by restraints  to prevent it from escaping and a  researcher using  scp-5871 slashed it erasing it from  existence from that point on a ck-class  reality restructuring event occurred and  post-restructured researchers were  unable to find any traces of scp-682  it seemed almost like it never existed  however soon after this the effects were  reversed by scp-682's adapting abilities  682 returned to reality then the test we  just described was erased from existence  as well as scp-5871